On your screen right
now are thousands of ancient galaxies...
brought to you in one of the first
five images
taken by the James
Webb Space Telescope or JWST.
The region captured here spans
as much of the sky
as a grain of sand would cover,
if held at arm's length.
The farther away these galaxies are,
the longer their light took to reach us.
This view reaches back
more than 13 billion years into the past.
But JWST isn't just witnessing history.
It's making it.
Launched in 2021 after more than 25 years
of planning, the space telescope traveled
1.5 million kilometers away from Earth
to give us a new view of the universe.
This is the Carina Nebula.
JWST can see deep into its clouds
and reveal stars as they form.
Our sun was actually born in a cloud
like this.
Here we see the opposite
end of a star's life cycle
through the Southern Ring Nebula.
At its center,
a star has run out of fuel and partially
exploded,
leaving behind beautiful ripples.
These ripples are one of the main ways
that elements like carbon, an important
building block for planets and life,
get spread throughout the universe.
Next is a group of galaxies
called Stephan's Quintet.
As these galaxies fall
closer to each other,
they're starting to swirl, like water
going down a drain.
With JWST, we can see thousands
of other galaxies in the background too.
Lastly, JWST measured light from a planet
called WASP 96b
orbiting another star in the Milky Way.
The signal shows
that this particular planet,
a gas giant like Jupiter, has clouds.
The telescope will look
for similar signals from rocky planets
that could potentially host life.
These images are just a glimpse of
what's to come.
JWST did all of this in a matter of days.
It has enough fuel for 20 years.